[Musique]
santé et prévention le cancer colorectal
touche chaque année plus de 43000
personnes alors que le taux de
participation dépistage n'est que de 33%
face à ce constat la Ligue contre le
cancer renouvelle le mois de
sensibilisation mars bleu pris en charge
assez tôt ce type de cancer peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 si vous avez
entre 50 ans et 74 ans vous pouvez vous
faire livrer un kit de dépistage à
domicile gratuitement quatrième édition
pour l'opération aux arbres citoyens à
Poissy dès aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 30
avril les picia quai volontaire peuvent
s'inscrire pour obtenir gratuitement un
arbre à planter dans leur jardin une
trentaine de ses végétaux seront
distribués aux habitants après un tirage
au sort cette initiative s'inscrit dans
la campagne de revégétalisation de la
commune dont l'objectif est de planter
1000 arbres d'ici 2025 le club de
village version 2023 a rouvert ses
portes au public ce mercredi après trois
ans de travaux l'association l'Union
nationale des centres sportifs de gère
désormais la structure en délégation de
service public de nouvelles activités
font leur apparition comme le foot A5 ou
le paddle des tarifs découvertes seront
proposés aux usagers jusqu'au 2 avril
prochain une nouvelle expérience pour
les fans de jeux vidéo la seconde salle
de réalité virtuelle Eva des Yvelines
ouvre aujourd'hui au bureau jusqu'à 10
joueurs équipés d'un casque VR et d'une
arme connectée peuvent s'affronter au
sein d'une arène de 500 mètres carrés
univers futuriste mêlant action et
stratégie ce concept 100% français et
présent dans 19 villes de France dont
Maurepas une légende s'est éteinte
aujourd'hui l'ancienne attaquant de
l'équipe de France de football juste
fontaine et décédé à l'âge de 89 ans
recordman du nombre de buts inscrits en
Coupe du monde avec 13 réalisations
pendant le Mondial 1958 il a aussi
entraîné le jeune club du Paris
Saint-Germain dans les Yvelines entre
1973 et 1976 permettant sa montée en
première division des 1974
[Musique]